[Music]  will there ever be a collaboration  between icp and sam hyde  probably for those who don't know sam  hyde he is a rapper goes by zany tanner  who would win in a tag team wrestling  match insane clown posse or kyle chapman  and sam hyde  oh geez yeah that's gonna be  that's gonna be a draw what are the odds  on that one are the vegas odds  i don't know what kyle chapman on that  one just because he's  american badass he's so based yeah i do  like the fact that she booked it though  like vince mcmahon style like nah it'll  be a tie and then we're going to wrap it  up at summerslam will there ever be  a collaboration between icp and sam hyde  i don't know who samad is he's uh he's  an indie rapper he goes by the name  zany tanner hey dude collaboration  between icp and sam hyde  you never know you never know all right  all right so uh  tomorrow they might surprise doesn't end  and tyler's gonna come out  in in a month